das war einfach unglaublich und dann
schaue ich da auf dieser Anzeigetafel
und es steht dafür wenn jemand anderen
Namen und hier wird es nicht soll ich
weinen und mich freuen lachen ich habe
es nicht ganz gewusst
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen beim Sportplatz dem
Sport Podcast das österreichischen
Bundesheers heute zu Gast
Europameisterschaft Medaillen Gewinner
im Schwimmen
die Bayern herzlich willkommen danke
Karriere mit der großen Krönung bei der
Europameisterschaft in Rom mit deiner
Medaille und deinen zwei großartigen
vierten Plätzen bekommen auch gleich
noch darauf zu sprechen aber erzähl mal
wie schaust du auf dieses Jahr zurück ja
war definitiv Mann erfolgreiches Jahr im
Profi schwarz zeige ich jetzt mal
Jugend war ja schon mal nicht so
schlecht aber jetzt das ist das Top
eigentlich alles ja Medaille war
unglaublich
cooles Gefühl
Plätze war richtig knapp aber
bin trotzdem sehr zufrieden mit der
Leistung mit dem was wir die letzten
Jahre gearbeitet haben und das ganze
Drumherum das hat alles super passt und
ich hoffe es geht weiter so das ist zwar
gesagt das war super knapp das war
wirklich wahnsinnig knapp man kennt das
vom skeleton Bobfahren etc Tausendstel
bei wahnsinnigen Geschwindigkeiten ja im
Schwimmen geht wirklich um hundertstel
wir haben auf 50 Meter Brust 800 gefehlt
und auf 100 m Brust 4 auf die Pause
wie geht man damit um als der Sportler
wenn es wirklich so eng beieinander
liegt ja in dem Fall ist das sehr
schwierig weil es doch ein bandstrecken
unglaubliche Bestzeit war
was ich mir auch so selber nicht
wirklich erwartet hätte wie gesagt es
ist sehr schwierig einerseits habe ich
mich sehr gefallen 100% österreichische
Rekord um ich glaube es waren fast vier
Zehntel verbessert
das ist eine halbe Sekunde bessert von
mir ja und das war einfach unglaublich
und dann schaue ich da auf diese Anzeige
dafür und es steht dafür wenn jemand der
Namen und ich habe jetzt nicht soll ich
weinen mich freuen lachen ich habe es
nicht ganz gewusst aber ich habe mich
auf jeden Fall sehr gefreut jetzt im
Endeffekt das heißt die Freude über den
österreichischen überwiegt auf jeden
Trauer über eine möglicherweise
verpasste Medaille ja Trauer würde ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen aber
eine leichte Enttäuschung also bisschen
ist das natürlich schon dabei aber es
war ein unglaublich cooles Rennen
unglaublich schwer unglaublich schwerer
Wettkampf und ich habe einfach mein
Bestes gegeben und das hat eben diesmal
leider so ausgeschaut nächstes Mal
vielleicht wieder anders aber wenn man
weiß wie groß die Konkurrenz ist auch
bei Europameisterschaften im Schwimmen
seine weltspart hatte im Endeffekt die
gesamte Welt schwimmt ganz Europa
schwimmt es gibt wahnsinnig große
Nationen in Europa die alles im
Schwimmen untergeordnet haben und dann
eben dort so knapp an der Medaille
vorbeizukommen in einer hochtechnischen
Sportler das Brustschwimmen ist das
vielleicht die einzige ein bisschen was
verstehe also das ist schon hoch
anzeichnen was sie dort gelungen ist
jetzt weiß ich dass dein Trainer in der
Südstadt sehr sehr kritisch auch ist
ich glaube er hat dasselbe gefühlt wie
ich gerade beschrieben habe was er
auf jeden Fall sehr zufrieden während
dem Rennen wage ich mich zu erinnern
dass er gemeint hat er war sehr
emotional dabei
und da gab es fast nichts außer
natürlich nach dem Feuer wir haben
Videoanalyse hin und her was kann man
doch noch in diesem kurzen Zeitraum in
der Mittagspause was kann ich mir dann
auch quasi vorstellen was ich da
verbessern kann und dann im Einschwimmen
vielleicht noch umsetzen und dann im
Wettkampf auch
also da waren wir schon noch sehr
kritisch unterwegs natürlich
vom Vorlauf auf Semifinale habe ich noch
mal zwei Zehntel ca verbessert und ja da
das sieht man schon dass das kritische
auch was bringt und ja aber
prinzipiell fahren wir dann beide sehr
happy weil wir haben ja sehr hart
gearbeitet dafür und so schaut eben dann
das Endresultat aus was kann man denn da
noch für Schräubchen drehen zwischen
ziemlich alle und Finale was waren da
diese 15 die sagen gesprochen hast deine
beste verbessert ist es die Wende ist
das der Anschlag ich meine 50er gibt
was was war es denn dass das so viel
Zeit noch ausgegangen auf jeden Fall
noch ein bisschen anders an der Wände
bisschen was besser gesagt am Tag Zug
nach der Wände ein bisschen was
gearbeitet und ein bisschen länger unter
Wasser halten du kennst dich da
vielleicht jetzt aus aber wieder nicht
so viel ins Detail gehen aber da haben
wir ein bisschen was gearbeitet also
gearbeitet sage ich jetzt einmal so dass
man eine kurze Anmerkung das kannst du
verbessern wenn es im Wettkampf nicht
funktioniert es geht alles so schnell
meistens nach dem Rennen denke ich mir
einfach habe ich jetzt die Wände
erwischt also das geht so schnell vorbei
da ist so viel Adrenalin dabei es ist
echt schwierig sich im Wettkampf auf
solche technischen Kleinigkeiten zu
konzentrieren das heißt man muss sie im
Training so drehen dass sie dann
wirklich perfekte automatisiert
abgerufen werden können vor allem beim
50er weil das gesagt dass es geht alles
so schnell im Endeffekt das sind 50
Meter das sind ähm 22 23 Züge ich weiß
nicht wie viel du brauchst um 50%. da
muss alles sitzen sobald man einen Zug
falsch macht weiß man dann auch schon
okay das war's jetzt das wenn man vorbei
ja das ist so schwierig das kannst du
nur im Training musst du das optimal
üben also wir haben da nicht nur
kraftmäßig Sachen dabei sondern auch
wirklich technisch hochanspruchsvolle
Kleinigkeiten die da passen müssen und
wenn die im Training nicht sitzen wird
im Wettkampf extrem schwer die dann doch
noch umzusetzen was dir dann dann doch
gelungen ist mit der Medaille nachdem
sie im Einzel ganz knapp oder nicht
geklappt hat war in der Staffel 4 x 100
Meter Lagen Staffel mit äh deinen drei
Kollegen das heißt man schwimmt in der
langstaffel den Rücken Brust kraulen und
normalerweise in der Staffel ist dann
umgekehrt dann fängt man glaube ich mit
dem Rücken gedacht
ja ja ich sage jetzt mal hier hin
um ein bisschen
Hintergrundgeschichte reinzubringen bei
der WM in Budapest damals hatten wir
schon ein sehr sehr gutes Rennen mit
österreichischen Rekord in der Staffel
sehr sehr gut verlaufen ein tolles
Becken in Budapest wir haben den siebten
Platz geholt unglaublich auf der Welt ja
dann haben wir uns eben im Vorlauf schon
gedacht
wir geben noch mal richtig Gas es war
schon der letzte Tag alles sehr müde
nicht nur für uns war das schwierig
sondern auch für die anderen Teams und
wir haben dann eben das Beste rausgeholt
und am Abend am Nachmittag waren wir
natürlich noch mal extra motiviert
nachdem wir ich glaube wir waren als
Zweiter im Finale wenn ich mich jetzt
recht erinnere ist ein bisschen schon
bisschen ja jetzt wieder aber
nein alles optimal verlaufen es war
einfach ein super geiles Feeling dort zu
stehen und vor allem nach meinen hundert
Metern noch die restlichen zwei
Schwimmer zu sehen und an zu feiern dass
ja wenn ich nicht vergessen hier legt
man das wenn man nicht mehr im Wasser
war man weiß man hat schon alles gegeben
man kann nichts mehr an der eigenen
Leistung verändern sie war gut oder
schlecht in deinem Fall gut dass dazu
beigetragen dass das die Staffel so
erfolgreich sein konnte wir lebt man
diese 200 Meter wo die anderen schwimmen
ja schwierig du hast gesagt du steigst
heraus vielleicht ein bisschen hilflos
weil du kannst dein Team nicht mehr
richtig du kannst ja nichts mehr ändern
an der Endzeit ganz offen dass die
anderen auch noch mal richtig Gas geben
und eine gescheite seit der reinhauen
aber
also selber ist er natürlich du denkst
du dir dann ja war das eh hat das eh
passt so von der Zeit her wie war das
jetzt wie schnell war ich überhaupt es
ist in der Staffel sehr schwer weil du
natürlich die Anzeige nicht hast aber ja
natürlich falls du an und ja auf dass du
das Beste gegeben hast natürlich und
dann die anderen dann auch geschafft
großartige Medaille ein absolutes ja
absolute
Wahnsinnsleistung also man kann das gar
nicht so hoch hoch einschätzen weil für
mich halt als der Schwimmer aber es hat
doch ein bisschen das Gefühl
weitergegeben dass ihr euch jetzt als
Mannschaft als Staffel auch sehr gut
versteht stimmt das ja also wir haben
dort auch unglaublichen Spaß gehabt auch
bei der bei der Vorbereitung für die
Siegerehrung da sind wir dann unten
gestanden und haben witziger gerissen
teilweise also war sehr sehr amüsanta
nachher aber ich glaube das als Staffel
außer dass es eine schwimmen ist ein
Einzelsport also wirklich absolut
Einzelsport so du weißt das aber in der
Staffel das ist halt wieder was anderes
natürlich da gibt es dann besser ist und
jeder andere Kollegen muss auch das
Beste geben weil sonst wird das
offensichtlich nichts
ja in der Hinsicht sind wir glaube ich
ein optimales Team was glaubst Du noch
möglich für seine Firma 100 lagen
Staffel der Herren in Österreich puh
hoffentlich viel
Mitarbeiter natürlich
hier wenn sich jeder noch gut verbessern
kann dann geht das sicher noch einiges
weiter auch über den Olympische Spiele
hoffe das ist natürlich unser nächstes
Ziel
Qualifikation für Olympia natürlich die
WM jetzt noch in fugoca das ist auch der
nächste wichtige Zwischenschritt vor
Olympia noch da wir uns wahrscheinlich
nicht infoca qualifizieren müssen müssen
wir auf die WM 24 warten in
wenn ich mich jetzt recht erinnere dort
gilt es dann dass wir uns qualifizieren
wirklich auch für Olympia das heißt der
Stufenplan ist schon ausgeziert damit
eine Staffel in Paris am Start ist sein
kann deine stärkste Konkurrenz über die
100 Meter Brust kommt der aus seinem
staffelte mich
reizhammer ein Schwimmbad der eigentlich
alles kann
gute stimmt auch die Lagen selbst sehr
sehr gut schwimmt das heißt natürlich
auch verschiedene Trainings Philosophien
eher als Allrounder du als Spezialist
und auch die Trainingsgruppen die
Trainings Philosophien er trainiert in
Linz Südstadt ist der anders aber
würdest du sagen ist der große
Unterschied zwischen dir und dem
Bernhard also hast du schneller bist
schwierig zu sagen weil ich nicht genau
weiß wie sie trainieren und wie sie das
ganze Hand haben ich glaube sie machen
sehr viel Krafttraining
wir machen ein bisschen weniger aber
im Endeffekt
wenn jetzt genauso hart und das ist was
zählt dann also wir haben bei der
unglaublich hart und im Endeffekt
gewinnt dann der Bessere
das ist das harte Training angesprochen
wie kann sich das vorstellen wie viel
Trainingszeit im Wasser wie viel
Trainingsumfang muss man als Schwimmer
überhaupt machen auf dieses Niveau zu
kommen ja eigentlich sehr individuell
sie Sprinter machen meistens bisschen
weniger Wasser mehr Krafttraining mehr
an landkrafttraining und ja ähm in wen
in der Südstadt mit dem Ballast
trainieren zehnmal die Woche jeweils
zwei Stunden
das nur im Wasser also 20 Stunden mal
wassereinheit und dann kommen noch dazu
auftraining Zirkel
Aufwärmen als natürlich Nachbereitung
denen Massagen was auch immer also da
kommt seine
Summe zusammen dann im Endeffekt was so
das Training direkt oder indirekt
betrifft
das bedeutet auch dass man eigentlich
relativ schnell sobald man im Schwimmen
erfolgreich sein möchte auch den Weg ins
profitum gehen muss wart Ihr schon immer
klar dass du schwimmprofi werden
möchtest ich ja immer das ist jetzt das
ist jetzt so dahingestellt
aber auf jeden Fall ist seit ich in der
Südstadt gekommen bin das war vorher
etwa acht Jahren achteinhalb
mittlerweile und da habe ich mir dann
gedacht wenn ich mir das schon Handtuch
dann richtig und ja jetzt sitze hier zum
Glück habe ich weiter gemacht war nicht
immer sehr einfach aber
absolut gezogen und jetzt gehen wir mal
hoffentlich bald die Laden gibt es
irgendwann auch Momente wo man sagt
keine Ahnung mit einer Woche Mittwoch
vormittag wenn die Einheit wieder acht
Kilometer lang ist wenn man sich denkt
warum mache ich das eigentlich hast Du
solche Momente nicht unbedingt am
Mittwoch aber natürlich ist immer sehr
schwer weil
z.B am Ende der Woche Freitag in der
früh 6 Uhr Krafttraining dann Wasser
machen wir auch Kraftübungen im Wasser
natürlich
sehr schwierig es ist aufzustehen um
fünf teilweise ist halt
richtig hardcore sage ich jetzt mal und
das geht schon an die Substanz nach
einer Weile aber wenn man durchbeißt
dann kann man das schaffen und da denke
ich immer dran wo ich hin will und dann
geht das bis leichter also ist das deine
Motivation zu wissen dass ich erreichen
möchte und damit es mir klar das gehört
halt dazu da muss ich jetzt durch ja das
da war jetzt die EM unglaublich
Gutachter für sowas z.B weil jetzt weiß
ich was was ich schon erreichen kann
wenn ich so so trainiere und ähm wenn
ich dann denke was ich noch erreichen
will dann natürlich ist das dahin
vielleicht dann war das glaubst auch
wichtig jetzt diesen Erfolg zu haben du
hast wahrscheinlich gesprochen dass sie
deine Medaillen gemacht auch bei
Großereignissen jetzt im
Erwachsenenbereich auch zu zeigen ich
bin mit deinen Kandidat ja es glaube ich
cool also das ist so weitergeht das in
nur weil im Jugend Bereiche Medaillen
macht als das nicht dass das auch
wirklich so weitergeht und deswegen bin
ich jetzt echt glücklich dass es
funktioniert hat also überhaupt dass ich
mal ins Finale gekommen bin ich als
hatte ich vorher nichts ich war schon
bei ihm bei zwei Ems dabei aber bin in
meinem semi Finale gescheitert und das
war jetzt Finale und gleich vierter
Platz und mit der Schlaf leben die
Medaille das ist
kann ich immer noch nicht in Worte
fassen ja es fällt mir immer noch
schwierig
Wahnsinns hilft es einfach unglaublich
das motiviert einen noch mehr
wann man für dich klar ich werde
Brustschwimmer ja war immer schon die
leichteste Lage für mich sage ich jetzt
mal also es war schon vor Jahren bin ich
nur diese Lage geschwommen und dann was
offensichtlich dass man das Weitermachen
welche Lage magst du überhaupt nicht
also nicht mögen es ist zum locker
schwimmen ist das super na aber
technisch Katastrophe
ich verstehe Dich sehr gut jetzt hast du
die Olympischen Spiele natürlich auch
mit der Staffel angegeben aber auch dein
Weg im Einzelfall zu den Olympischen
Spielen gehen das musst du dafür alles
schaffen oder erreichen und dich zu
qualifizieren prinzipiell mal 500
schneller schwimmen im nächsten Quali
weltkampf durch die EM und die
Wettkämpfe jetzt zu Beginn der Saison
haben wir schon wieder unglaublich viele
Erfahrungen gesammelt
viel auch nicht nur über den Wettkampf
auch über das Training was was tun wenn
Training wie was ist wenn wir bisschen
mehr als das machen und bisschen mehr so
was anderes in die Richtung so werden
wir hoffentlich noch paar Hundertstel
vielleicht auch ein paar Zehntel
ausgequetschen
hoffentlich bis zur WM dann infogoca
aber ja ist natürlich das große Ziel da
noch bisschen die Zeit unterdrücken und
ich hoffe das geht gut diesmal 500 nicht
zu viel natürlich im Schwimmen kann das
eine Welt sein und vor allem das
passieren dass man oft knapp weil wenn
es um Kleinigkeiten geht in dieser Zeit
nicht schafft aber es ist schon
Motivation weiß so weit weg ist dieses
Limit jetzt nicht also wenn das Limit
irgendwie eine Sekunde weit weg wäre
würde das deinen Zugang verändern es ist
auf jeden Fall sehr sehr realistisch
jetzt diese 500 jetzt ist das erste Mal
der nächste Schritt das mindestens
genauso schwer wie die Zeit im Sommer zu
schwimmen ist die Zeit noch einmal in
einem anderen Wettkampf zu schwimmen ist
mindestens gleich schwer und dann noch
mal die 500l ja wenn der Tag passt also
bisschen was wieder das ist das bisschen
tagesabhängig manchmal geht es besser
manchmal nicht
was soll ich sagen
es ist unglaublich motivierend natürlich
als wenn einer Sekunde da fehlt dann ist
das ein bisschen schwierig ich habe mich
schon schwer getan vor Tokio wollte ich
das Leben unbedingt schwimmen
hat dann leider im Endeffekt nicht so
gut funktioniert da hat er auch nicht
mehr so viel gefehlt das waren ziemlich
genau 13 damals jetzt sind es 500s
nochmal um einiges weniger aber sicher
genauso schwierig wobei man da anmerken
muss dass sich das Limit mittlerweile
noch einmal natürlich unglaubliche
Steigerung bei den Limits wo auch immer
das herkommt auf einmal es bleibt ein
Rätsel für mich also mit einer
derzeitigen des Zeit wärst du klar unter
dem Limit
ähm also das muss man natürlich die
Entwicklung da so sehen jetzt kommen aus
der Südstadt dort wo du trainierst in
den letzten Jahren auch Medaille
Gewinner aber vor allem sehr viele
Teilnehmer bei Europameisterschaften
Weltmeisterschaften
ganz normal früher noch bei euch
trainiert was ist das Erfolgsgeheimnis
in der Südstadt ja ich denke es ist ein
optimales Trainingszentrum du hast
ca alles was man brauchen kann im Umfeld
es gibt ein Internat Massagen sind
nebenan kann man sich holen weil
Kaltwasser Warmwasser gibt ja
Kraftkammer ist ich glaube es gibt drei
kraftkammern also wenn man da kein Platz
zum Trainieren hat dann ja wäre das ich
weiß nicht was man dann tut aber ja das
ist ja sehr optimal geregelt dort das
Schwimmbecken ist also wird es schlimmer
sag jetzt mal das Schwimmbecken ist sehr
gut zum Trainieren ja
ich glaube das wäre mein gutes
Trainerteam jetzt mit drei Tränen
mittlerweile und relativ viel Nachwuchs
mal schauen was er in den nächsten
Jahren zukommt hoffentlich einiges ja
wir werden dann wohl doch noch eine
Stimme Nation werden bist du wieder
Wettkampf Typ oder eher der Training
schwierig zu beantworten ich schwimme
sehr sehr gerne im Wettkampf aber sollte
der Wettkampf mal nicht gut
funktionieren dann bin ich wieder
richtig heiß aufs Training also es ist
immer so ein Wechselspiel bisschen wenn
es lange Training schon lange
Vorbereitungsphasen das tat sich dann
schon und wartet man dann nur richtig
auf dem Wettkampf und komm lass mich
jetzt mal raus aus dem Käfig und richtig
Gas geben quasi dann wenn der Wettkampf
vorbei ist und du denkst ja sowas so
eine Idee wie kannst vielleicht
schneller gehen dann ist auch wieder
heiß aufs Training und denkst du ja mach
mal bisschen da Technik bisschen anders
und dann geht schon wieder und dann
kommt wieder von vorne dann denkst du
wieder komm lass mich in Wettkampf und
Gas geben also
es ist und dann hat sie entschieden die
kurzen Weltmeisterschaft letztes Jahr
auszulassen also offensichtlich auch
wenn man natürlich Gas geben möchte und
und performen möchte gibt es größere
Entscheidungen auf die man achten muss
warum habt ihr denn die die
Weltmeisterschaft in Australien
ausgelassen das war
schon eine recht schwierige Entscheidung
natürlich bin jetzt nicht so ein
kurzbein Freund wieder vielleicht weißt
aber dennoch einen Weltmeisterschaft und
dazu melden auch noch glaube ich wie oft
man kommt man schon nach Australien
allerdings ist eben das ja wie kommt man
überhaupt nach Australien das sind
glaube ich 20 Stunden Flugzeit und fast
nicht wie viele Stunden Zeitverschiebung
und äh haben wir uns dann gedacht es ist
besser wir bleiben hier in der Südstadt
in Österreich
und trainieren weiter schauen wir noch
einen langbaren Wettkampf
ja schauen dass wir das Training optimal
hinbekommen und bereiten uns möglichst
gut auf die nächsten Wettkämpfe vor die
dann bald auch Qualle weltkämpfe sind
wieder das heißt den größeren Ziel
sozusagen dieses kleine Ziel ist ja da
wird dieses große Ziel also dieses
übergeordnete Ziel Olympia natürlich
steht dann darüber und dann werden den
die WM oder so wird dann bisschen
natürlich untergeordneter dazu muss man
natürlich auch verstehen dass so eine
sich aus dem Training für so eine
Weltmeisterschaft dann herauszunehmen
dass impliziert automatisch ein paar
Wochen wo man anders trainiert natürlich
darum ist es gegangen das ist ein
unglaublicher teilaufwand nicht nur das
Fliegen
sondern auch du trainierst dann zwei
Wochen vorher ab danach ist gleich
Weihnachten da drin ist oder dann auch
eine Woche nicht und dann bist du
automatisch sechs Wochen nicht so
richtig im Training sondern schon so im
Wettkampfmodus dann auch im
weihnachtsmodus und dann nach sechs
Wochen so richtig anfangen soll ich
natürlich auch im Kopf bisschen
schwierig wieder vielleicht weiß dass
das Sommerpause ist das immer am
härtesten eigentlich und das wollte man
vermeiden und die fehlende natürlich für
die ähm ja für den harten Teil wirklich
Qualifikation geht bei mir ist jedes
Training im Kopf haben
weil das kann mit dem Alter kommen wir
zur Abschlussrunde lieber Valentin was
wolltest du denn als Kind werden oh
ursprünglich wollte ich gleich mal
Feuerwehrmann werden
was mich fasziniert mich eigentlich
immer noch
vielleicht willst Du doch noch was
schauen wir mal was wäre es denn ohne
deinen Sport derzeit wahrscheinlich
arbeitslos
was ist deine stärkste Eigenschaft ich
weiß nicht jetzt unbedingt ob sie
stärker ist manche würden noch sagen ist
eine etwas bisschen was negatives aber
ich bin unglaublich stur teilweise ja es
geht viel Spaß meine stärkste
Eigenschaft
meine Familie wird vielleicht sagen
nicht aber das lasse ich jetzt mal so
stehen was ist denn größtes Talent
wahrscheinlich schwimmen aber und das
ist Talent ist nicht schlimm ist also
dass Dir nichts bringt nichts bringt das
ist schwer zu sagen wahrscheinlich
schlafen
in dem Sport aber das bringt ihm schon
auf jeden Fall sehr viel wovon träumst
du wenn du schläfst oder wenn du nicht
schläfst wenn du wach bist das ist dein
Traum
auf jeden Fall gibt's den Olympia Damen
und seit zwei sportlich zu bleiben
aber ja ich möchte sagen es wäre schön
nachher genauso erfolgreich zu sein nach
meinem sportlichen leben
Olympia 20 24
gehen das wünschen wir natürlich alles
Gute danke danke
das nächste Mal bis dann
[Applaus]